good morning Hank it's Tuesday I've been
thinking a lot about bread specifically
about what bread tasted like right
before the women's March on Versailles
in 1789 in which a group of French women
who were depending on your perspective
either protesting or rioting besieged
the king's palace in Versailles and
forced him and his family to return to
Paris it was a big moment in the French
Revolution and it was caused in part by
bread mostly the price of bread which
had risen dramatically due to failed
harvests and bad monetary policy but
also the quality of bread which always
declined in hard times like the French
peasant bread of 1789 often included
lots of chaff the undigestible husks
surrounding the edible kernel of grain
and wheat but it was also common to bulk
up wheat or rye or buckwheat dough with
sawdust or hay or even animal dung and
at the time bread wasn't just like a
staple of the French diet for most
people it was the diet like the average
French adult ate two to three pounds of
bread per day every day and while they
did sometimes have access to other foods
many days possibly most days it was just
bread sawdusty possibly animal poopie
bread I've been reading about this
partly for the cooking history videos
that Sarah and I are gonna make later in
the year and partly because I don't know
I just fall down research rabbit holes
like I'm reading one book and then
another and pretty soon I'm looking up
five thousand-year-old recipes for grain
paste and my kids are like dad can you
make breakfast and I'm like oh my god
it's morning anyway the thing that gets
me about bread is not how shockingly
horrible it used to be it's how recently
it was shockingly horrible like you know
Halley's Comet or possibly Halley's
Comet or Holly's comment depending on
whose pronunciation you believe it's
this comet that is visible from Earth
every 75 is years so like a good human
lifetime the last time Haley was visible
from Earth in 1986 I was 8 the time
before that was 1910 and the time before
that Louie the sixteenths cousin
Philippe the first was King of France
having become King after the so-called
second French Revolution which was
caused in part by you guessed it failed
harvests and rising bread prices put
another way we are two human lifetimes
removed from the u.s. Civil War and only
three removed from a time when not just
the poorest people but most people were
eating sawdust bread in France of course
this doesn't mean that we've achieved
some great victory that we ought to
celebrate or anything there are still
lots of people who don't get out of
nutrition and not only in impoverished
countries but also in wealthy ones but
it does mean that we can make progress
and when you look at history through the
lens of life times both the pace of
change and the nature of change are to
me really encouraging and frankly I
could use some encouragement in these
strange times because I find that
despair mostly just makes me complacent
like oh there's nothing to be done about
this horror or that horror it's just the
nature of things on the other hand
feeling like progress is inevitable also
makes me complacent like oh I can just
sit back and watch rising grain yields
feed the world an Elan musk fix climate
change and disease cure itself but
reading history fills me with the
uncomfortable but productive feeling
that better human lives are possible but
not guaranteed
of course it's overly simplistic to say
that the women who led the march on
Versailles brought about a freer more
equitable less hungry France the French
Revolution like so many revolutions
failed to achieve many of its ambitions
in my experience anyway the changes we
seek in the world almost always prove
harder to make than we first think
they'll be but looking at history in
lifetimes shows us that change can and
does happen anyway something I'm
reminded of every time I bite into a
nice sawdust free slice of bread Hank
I'll see you on Friday